à dix jours de la reprise du championnat
de ligue 2 les joueurs du tfc ont repris
le chemin de l'entraînement depuis déjà
quelques semaines enchaînant les matches
amicaux la saison prochaine si le club
devra se passer de son gardien bien gros
camara par sia strasbourg
il pourra compter sur quatre nouvelles
recrues outre romain bayard et jordan
paupineau le ts et renforce ses
effectifs avec florian makhedjouf formé
au psg ancien milieu de terrain du red
star et amr bouâzza 32 ans international
algérien également passé par le red star
et la première league anglaise très
content d'être un jour de tour excès
après c'est vrai que on a eu une
carrière assez intéressante mais
maintenant j'en ai aujourd'hui on est on
est on est concentrés au club de tours
fc s'est pas vraiment apporter mon
expérience et apporter un plus à
l'équipe et j'espère vraiment vivre une
très belle saison avec avec tours fc
en espérant faire de belles choses de
son idylle berline kean l'entraîneur
pourra également s'appuyer sur rave et
lauzon tall etcheverria ou encore
couderc qui viennent de signer leur
premier contrat professionnel du sang
neuf pour une équipe qui devra faire ses
preuves
après une saison passée quelque peu
chaotique le tfc était arrivé 16e du
classement en début de saison on a perdu
beaucoup de matches et c'est vrai que ça
nous a mis un peu dans le dur pendant
pendant une bonne partie du championnat
donc déjà essayé de d'entamer la
meilleure des manières le championnat
pour pouvoir avoir une saison tranquille
en matière n'est alors peut-être des
ambitions autres que ce qu'on a eu
l'année dame but et pour l'année à venir
10 millions d'euros côté objectif
justement le président ne cache pas ses
ambitions
finir dans les deux premiers pour éviter
la relégation
ce vent et le finir le plus haut
possible
c'est à dire très rares espagnols à
chaque lavage enchères
la première année c'est à dire
applicable a donc laissé le citronnier
et puis chemin faisant nous verrons que
vous savez que cette année nous avons
les cinq premiers se prétendre à monter
les premiers directs et la 3e 4e 34 jean
charest lors du dernier match amical
pour les ciel et noir vendredi face à
cholet reprise du championnat le 28
juillet avec un match à domicile face au
havre